l'ananas lequel vu revenir sur les
tables martiniquaise après les années
fastes début 2000 où la production
culminait à 20 mille tonnes contre 4
cents seulement aujourd'hui une dizaine
d'années culture sont déterminés à
relancer la filière comme ici à basse
pointe et ils ont des arguments
qualitatifs notamment avec en plus de la
grosse et juteuse md2 une nouvelle
variété la queen mcgregor a les plus
sucrées et plus croquant après ça dépend
des goûts de chacun mais elle un réel
avantage agronomique pour les
producteurs parce qu'elle est beaucoup
plus résistantes aux maladies malgré une
baisse de rendement de 15 à 20% elle est
beaucoup plus résistantes aux maladies
donc ça permet aux producteurs de voir
l'avenir un peu plus sereinement
moi d'être en de pastis alors il faut
savoir qu'on ananas déjà nous avons fait
le choix de zéro pesticide sur le fruit
dont quand le consommateur achète un
produit d'ananas martini que ce soit de
la md dur de la queen mcgregor et à zéro
pesticide souffrir face aux produits
importés du costa rica ou de saint
domingue bien moins vertueux du point de
vue phytopharmaceutiques jean-claude
capron et sa coopérative refuse de
l'itie se perdre le savoir-faire
pour marquer sa différence sur le marché
local il cultive au côté de la variété
md 2 15% de queen mcgregor lancé il y a
quatre ans cette variété souffrent de
petites tâches sans impact du statique
ou sanitaire mais qui rebutait parfois
les consommateurs
nous reconnaissait m était la mère très
secret mais d'acheter
beaucoup travaillé là beaucoup travaillé
dessus on a constaté que c'est la preuve
en azote il favorise l étage on a
diminué en a des milliers des fêtes et
lisa sion là on a mis en place elle a
bien cadré aujourd'hui en action avec
quand même que peu des tâches très très
très peu des dents mais que aujourd'hui
on est en train de faire la promotion
pour le faire connaître et de faire
adopter par le
seul marché martiniquais pour absorber
1500 tonnes par an soit trois fois plus
que la production actuelle
le plan pluriannuel lancé l'année
dernière semble structurer la petite
filière sur des bases solides une chance
fouad acheté l'année dernière un travail
commencé avec la grande distribution
et voilà la filière qui pourra ainsi
prendre son envol